you actually saw one of Robin Williams
early performances where his energy was
so extreme and his style was so
avantgarde you know for those of you on
acid this is a frisbee and running
around the stage road jacking off like a
robot Japanese man and it was all
discombobulated in and inside a hill it
killed and I thought mmm that I don't
know if I could do that yeah I
interviewed him when I was going to San
Francisco I was doing and I interviewed
him for a paper in a class Wow and I
remember at old tape recorder and he was
from Detroit and Marin but he had this
kind of almost a British accent in this
deep voice so I go do you have any goals
and showbusiness he goes I just want to
play for the people you know and I
thought wow what a cool voice yeah and I
just want to play for the people he come
to our house like Paula my Paula and
Paula Poundstone lived together at a
house in San Francisco and that became
the comedy club house and Robin would
come over with his first wife Valerie
and he bring I did I tried cocaine once
and burst into tears so it wasn't my
thing just saw me write one second of
high and then why am I even alive right
but he would bring a giant thing of
cocaine and everyone would come over and
we play ping pong all night I can't
imagine him on cocaine because I mean
the guy is frantic as it is it was
paranoia I mean we had a curtain was
mill the night in San Francisco and he'd
be looking up I thought he was kidding
oh dear they're coming soon better go
down there oh don't be afraid as a very
shy delicate man really a very very nice
sweet Pam he it at one points that I'm
sorry maybe some people say I might have
taken some things from you and he's been
very sweet about it and I said Robin I
tried to take your entire aah I tried to
take her I had a trunk of props I mean I
I tried to be him and then I realized I
couldn't be you were honored if he stole
from you totally yeah you know and then
I finally slowed things down and develop
my own style years later but at first it
was like he was the gold standard he was
the Godfather